New chat GPT update is insane.
Open AAI just dropped a brand new chat
GPT update. It's called GPT 5.3 instant.
And honestly, this thing is a gamecher.
Today, I'm going to show you exactly
what changed, why it matters, and how
you can use it right now. This is big.
This is new. And by the end of this
video, you're going to want to try it
yourself. So, let's get into it. Okay,
so here's the deal. Chat GPT just got
way better. like way better. And I'm not
just saying that. Open AAI literally
came out and said this new update is
built to be more accurate, more natural,
and less cringe. Yeah, they actually use
the word cringe. And you know what?
They're right. Because if you've been
using chat GPT for a while, you know
exactly what I'm talking about. Those
weird preachy responses, the
over-the-top disclaimers, the robotic
tone that makes you feel like you're
talking to a textbook. That stuff gone,
or at least way less of it now. So, what
is GPT 5.3 Instant? simple. It's the
newest default model inside chat GPT. It
started rolling out on March 3rd, 2026.
So, if you open Chat GPT right now, you
might already have it. And if you're a
developer, you can access it through the
API, too. The model name is GPT 5.3 chat
latest. So, you can plug it straight
into your apps, your tools, your
workflows, whatever you're building.
Now, here's where it gets really
interesting. And pay attention because
this part matters. The biggest upgrade,
fewer hallucinations. And if you don't
know what that means, it's when chat GPT
just makes stuff up. Like it sounds
confident, it sounds right, but it's
totally wrong. That's a hallucination.
And with GPT 5.3 instant, OpenAI says
they've cut hallucinations by up to
26.8%
when you're using web search. That is
huge. Think about that. Over a quarter
of the wrong answers just wiped out. If
you're using chat GPT for research, for
writing, for anything where accuracy
matters, this is massive. But wait,
there's more. And this next part is
something I've been wanting for a long
time. The tone is better. Like actually
better. You know how before you'd ask
chat GPT a simple question and it would
give you this long careful tiptoeing
answer with a million disclaimers like
you asked it what time it is and it gave
you a lecture on time zones. That's
done. GPT 5.3 talks like a normal person
now. It's smoother. It's more direct. It
doesn't add all that extra fluff that
nobody asked for. And honestly, that
alone makes it worth the update. Hey, if
we haven't met already, I'm the digital
avatar of Julian Goldie, CEO of Goldie
Agency. Whilst he's helping clients get
more leads and customers, I'm here to
help you get the latest AI updates.
Julian Goldie reads every comment, so
make sure you comment below. Okay, so
let's keep going because there's even
more to this update. Another big change
is fewer refusals. You know when you ask
chat GBT something totally normal and it
just says no, like it thinks your
question is somehow dangerous or weird
when it's completely fine. That was so
annoying. and OpenAI heard us. They
listen to the feedback. GPT 5.3 Instant
is way less likely to refuse normal
everyday questions. It actually tries to
help you now instead of acting like a
nervous hall monitor. And then there's
the web search thing. This is cool. So
when chat GPT searches the web for you,
it used to be a bit clunky. Sometimes it
would lean too hard on web results.
Sometimes it would ignore them. It was
inconsistent. With GPT 5.3, it's way
better at balancing what it knows
internally with what it finds online.
So, you get answers that are both smart
and current, best of both worlds. Now,
let me tell you why this update is
actually a big deal beyond just the
features because there's a bigger
picture here and most people are missing
it. OpenAI is shifting. They're not just
chasing speed and benchmarks anymore.
They're focusing on how chat GPT
actually feels to use. Think about that.
Instead of saying, "Hey, look, our model
is 10% faster on this random test,"
they're saying, "Hey, we made it less
annoying to talk to." That's a huge
shift. And it tells you something
important about where AI is going. It's
going toward real practical everyday
usefulness, not just tech specs. And
this matters for you, whether you're a
business owner, a creator, a student, or
just someone who uses chat GPT every
day. Because a better chat GPT means
better results for whatever you're
doing. Better content, better research,
better answers, less time fixing
mistakes, less time fighting with the
tool, more time actually getting stuff
done. Now, here's something I want you
to think about, and this is where it
gets real. If you're not using AI in
your business or your workflow right
now, you are behind. Full stop. Tools
like Chat GPT are getting better every
single month. And the people who are
using them are moving faster, working
smarter, and getting more done than
everyone else. That's just the reality.
And if you want to learn how to actually
use AI to scale your business, get more
customers, and automate the stuff that's
eating up your time, you need to check
out my AI profit boardroom. It's the
best place to learn how to use tools
like Chat GPT and GPT 5.3 Instant to
automate your workflows and grow your
business with AI. I'll drop the link in
the comments and description. Seriously,
go check it out. Okay, so let's talk
about some practical stuff. How can you
actually use GPT 5.3 instant right now?
First, if you're a content creator, this
is gold. The better tone means you can
use chat GPT for drafts, scripts,
outlines, and it's going to sound way
more natural. less editing for you, less
time cleaning up robotic language.
That's a win. Second, if you do any kind
of research, the hallucination reduction
is huge. You can trust the answers more,
not blindly, obviously. Always double
check important stuff, but 26.8% fewer
wrong answers. Means you're starting
from a much better place. Third, if
you're a developer, the API access means
you can build this into your own tools
right now. Your chat bots, your apps,
your automations, they all just got
smarter overnight. Fourth, if you're in
SEO or digital marketing, this matters,
too. Better web search integration means
Chat GPT is pulling in better, more
current data. That means better keyword
research, better content ideas, better
competitive analysis, all of it. Now,
let me answer some questions I know
you're going to have. Is GPT 5.2 going
away? Not yet. Open AAI is keeping it
around as a legacy option until June
3rd, 2026. So, you've got time to switch
over. But honestly, there's no reason
not to switch. Now, GPT 5.3 is just
better. Does this work in other
languages? Yes, but OpenAI says they're
still improving non-English performance.
So, if you're working in English, you'll
see the biggest improvements right now.
Other languages are getting better, too,
just not as fast. Do you need to do
anything to get it? Nope. If you're
using Chat GPT, it should update
automatically. Just open it up and start
chatting. You might already be on GPT
5.3 and not even know it. Now, here's
one more thing I want to share before we
wrap up. And I think this is really
important. The speed of AI updates is
only getting faster. Like, we just had
GPT 5.2 and now GPT 5.3 is already here.
These updates are coming quick. And each
one is a step up. Each one makes AI more
useful, more reliable, more practical.
The people who stay on top of this stuff
are the ones who win. The people who
ignore it get left behind. That's just
how it works. So, here's what I want you
to do. First, go try GPT 5.3 Instant
right now. Open Chat GPT, ask it
something, see the difference for
yourself. Second, if you want to take
this further and learn how to actually
use AI tools like this to automate your
business and get more customers, join
the AI profit boardroom. I've got
step-by-step processes, AI automation
workflows, and a community of people who
are all using this stuff to grow. The
link is in the comments and description.
Go join now while it's fresh in your
mind. And if you want the full process,
SOPs, and over 100 AI use cases like
this one, join the AI success lab. It's
a free community. Links in the comments
and description. You'll get all the
video notes from there, plus access to
our community of 38,000 members who are
crushing it with AI. Hit like if this
was helpful. Subscribe if you want more
AI updates like this, and drop a comment
below telling me what you think of GPT
5.3 Instant. Julian reads every single
one. I'll see you in the next one.